for me Jan is one of those players who's
incredibly fast yeah he plays quickly
regardless whether he's winning or even
when he's losing when I'm losing I tend
to stop and for players when they're
winning as well they want to be precise
and I think this is one of Yan's biggest
strength and like all strengths it can
sometimes be his biggest weakness as
well where we see sometimes this rash
quick play that messes up an advantage
and I wonder if that move 86 allowing
this entire tactics these sequence of
moves I think it was Blitz out on the
board uh it wasn't a position that Yan
wanted but again just one of those
moments where he doesn't take a pause
doesn't slow down and ends up in this
and when you're playing a rapid game and
your opponent plays a move sacrifices
gets up like we saw Sam savan do you
know you're in big trouble